and of course everybody
this stupid [ __ ] what happened to me so
if you guys have been watching my
channel for quite a while
or if you guys know me you know i don't
have the best
luck and usually when it comes to bad
luck i tend to spread that to the
closest people to me
sorry dear
[Laughter]
i love her so if you've been following
me on instagram of course i update my
life but i have a slight tear
in my meniscus it's been healing for
three weeks well my knee finally started
to feel a little bit better
so i decided to kind of hit the back
outside of my apartment and it's not
really a bag it's just get a little uh
this kicking shield that i tied to a two
by four so as i'm working out around six
o'clock
i get a call out here today uh getting
my boxing in because
uh yeah your boy's going a little crazy
so i need to stay active
uh this knee is acting up but today
we're trying to test it out and see
me mother is calling the [ __ ]
[Music]
my dog goes missing so remember back in
the day i showed you this dog named
booney so bunny
uh is still my dog but my parents have a
really big backyard back in sacramento
there's other dogs there and while i'm
in la i don't have a large place for her
to roam around
so i thought it would be better for the
dog to just leave
my dog with my parents until i get a
bigger spot
on
so last night we find this picture of
boonie where she ran away somebody picks
her up and we happen to find a lady
who is a a weirdo in the sense that yes
thank you very much for finding our dog
thank you for
uh taking care of her but this lady
would not give our dog back
without stipulations she went on this
whole tirade well if it was my dog this
wouldn't happen and already first of all
when it comes to that type of rhetoric
you're already pissing somebody off i
just lost my dog i ain't trying to hear
that [ __ ]
and what most people don't realize is
not that you're doing something wrong
it's the way that you say things that
piss people off
then she starts throwing out these
random random stipulations saying that
she will not give our dog back unless
we go to a vet place with her and we get
her chipped in our name or she won't
give us back well first of all
what the [ __ ] is going on she's calling
no number hey uh she's calling me i'm
gonna
have to hang up okay all right bye
hello hi hi sorry
my voice is starting to go um i'll just
i'll go ahead and meet him at their
house now i'm making this right i just
don't
know where and then
you know they're older i don't want them
driving around where they don't know and
just make it easier and then if yeah if
they just
promise to get her chipped i just worry
for you guys if
because you may not get lucky on someone
legit that wants
her to go home yeah yeah so after about
two hours of talking to her on the phone
mario has finally negotiated terms
and she is going to drop off the dog in
front of our parents house so i don't
even know she's going to give the dog
back
because booty might not react the way
that she normally does when she see my
parents and she might not want to give
her back
but it's just been a whole [ __ ]
ordeal that's what's going on right now
it would have it would
happen to me
okay just got out the shower
but before i showered i had a
conversation with my dad
and there is something that i do want to
mention
number one i am not a perfect human
being
and uh in these high and intense
situations
i tend to flip my ship
talking to my dad my dad said something
very important that i want to share with
you guys
that um kind of hit me right because i
was very upset about how this lady was
handling the situation though yes
she took care of my dog she received a
dog from somebody else and she's
somebody that is a dog lover when we
reached out to the best of her ability
she tried to verify that we were the
actual owners
though i didn't agree with the way that
she was going about it even after she
found out we are the owners and would
you know didn't want to give us back
until we chipped her which was very odd
because that's my personal choice
whether i want to put a chip in my dog
or not
my dad says something very important he
goes david you're upset and the way that
she went about things and how she's
choosing to kind of tell us what to do
with
with our dog um isn't right but
at the end of the day you have to look
at people's intent she intended to give
our dog back
she took care of our dog and we should
be very grateful that somebody actually
found her
and wanted to return it to us at the end
of the day her intent
was to make sure that that dog went to
its rightful owner so you got to look at
the woman's heart and that really
resonated with me because i think that's
something that i am trying to do
i'm trying to understand that sometimes
when people do bad things to you
or they do things that annoy you or get
under your skin
when you look at the intent of something
it really helps you understand somebody
else's situation
and why they're doing the things that
they're doing and on top of that it
allows you to navigate through these
conversations and these awkward social
situations and really helps you manage
your anger but before this video ends i
do want to say
uh thank you everybody for helping me
find my dog
diem um there was a couple of other
people i can't remember your names right
now it's just been a [ __ ]
[ __ ] of a day but if anything else i
appreciate the fan base because i don't
think i realized
how willing you guys are to help me it's
so
odd like i sometimes i feel like when
i'm trying to do things on my own that
the only person that can help me is
myself
but i decided to reach out to you guys
and you guys actually found my dog
amazing i i mean what do i say to that
what do i say we're learning every day
man i'm learning about some of the bad
behaviors that i have and the bad
temperament that i have
and uh i'm i'm gonna try to get better
it's not gonna be perfect but to the
woman that found my dog thank you very
much
um and i appreciate it all right pop it
off baby pop it off
i'll see you all next time